oh it's wild 94 one man the bootleg cap
show tonight is gonna be a movie at Club
Sky ladies and gentlemen it's gonna be
movie because we got this gentleman in
town sitting in front of me he's got the
hottest song in the world right now
ot Genesis yeah yo so uh you've been to
Tampa before yeah yeah yeah Club sky
before I know it's gonna be a movie I
get to come back here correct so yeah
you've been on the grind for a long time
man like I remember the first time I
heard of you had a record I'll call
Jackie Chan yeah that was probably
laying in the bay yeah yeah it's
probably like yeah yeah yeah and then of
course touchdown was a big record all
right scoffs all right yeah and now you
got the smash yeah how hard was it gonna
like be patient through all that because
I thought those two records didn't
necessarily pop off the way yeah you
know you you probably wanted them to
yeah it was mine it was real man
especially like you know you've been on
like all the blog sites and just
watching and then watching all this just
blow up and like all this stuff
happening in front of your face and you
sitting there you ask myself what am I
doing wrong right no I'm saying and then
the the most advice and somebody could
give to you like the craziest advice
somebody ever gave to me it was so
simple in cliche just keep lying there
yeah and I never know what that meant
until now you know what I'm saying like
you never know what happens so it's just
I just kept you know me kept putting my
foot on the gas man and working man
no yes movie time yeah I mean you could
have I usually got discouraged and you
know right right right right but I'm
like went back to the Coco for real
you're right so you know me I just kept
my foot on the gas man and I'm here I'm
ready to turn up now okay so I know you
got Long Beach connections
yeah are you from Long Beach you from
the band where you young really from
Long Beach okay so you're from Long
didn't really know me how are you
27 27 so we're the same age so yeah okay
so you grew up like like a like East
Side East Side his albums were dropping
when you were like
inside of the East Siders was popping
Dipset was popular yeah you have any any
any uh like any any relationship of any
of the LBC oh geez like I like snoop
like like yeah yeah it's new gear
definitely snoop like me it's new
chopped up all the time we got some we
got a show to UM I forgot where that
said like like do you find it like um a
lot of people are kind of boxing you
into like the trap music cuz Coco Coco
Coco kind of like you know what's that
sound it's hot right now right right
crazy in the club rebel being from Long
Beach like you would have to tell
somebody that you're from Long Beach for
them to know right right right because
musically they don't give the air but I
always I always stayed in my own name
you know I'm saying like one of us like
I always say to my whole name and I saw
I came with the name of Genesis you know
me you know it means a beginning but it
was just the beginning of a new sound on
that side you know I'm saying so that's
I came up with the name period but I
always was in my own name but I don't
got a problem with nobody putting me in
a box I mean as long as they're giving
you money as long as yes as long as you
couldn't attack man I'm all good with
that you know I'm saying it and if in
you know if I felt some type of way
about it then I just show on um with the
coco record it seemed like I remember
seeing like at first I'm just seeing on
Instagram like everybody from New York
was really into it and then I watched
the video yeah I didn't I didn't even
like I knew I would record but I didn't
know you know yeah I mean what it's
about I didn't know was on break out on
the radio right did you guys know like
this was the one man how long I know
before you knew I knew that because
originally I was gonna put out a
different record but then maybe like I
was in shoot a video and then like I
think like a week prior to me shooting
with with you know the date is already
there everything I was just like now I'm
going with this one so I still had to
end up shooting out the video for the
other song but I was like nah man going
with this one I knew what this was to me
and I mean I thought it was I thought it
was a hit to me in my eyes
but I never knew what this when I when I
thought I was like you know this this
record is real so when you got brought
out my wizard was was wiling out right
Oh like jumping in the crowd that
recognized man that was a movie in there
yeah that was crazy
hos crazy what is the one celebrity or
person like that has like surprised you
that they know your song because you
know you know like like pops from a
highly questionable on ESPN always is
like quote and rap song right somebody
who's like out of our realm that that
has like like you know acknowledged the
record that you've been like you know
you have to be it had to be Miley Miley
Cyrus yeah yeah it had to be her you
know say well it doesn't surprise you on
God said but but it's a pretty
surprising deal yeah it was a big deal
you know I mean but um other than a had
to be Timbaland
yeah that's that's a big deal yeah so
yeah um you originally we're talking I
totally forgot that you were rolling
with 50 for a minute yeah
now you've signed to g-unit kind of I
was on being all signs our own jr. I
don't want a single do was that burger
touchdown just see no it was for this
one Jackie said okay and so um signed
over there for a single do and then you
know kept crying and then I just touched
down touchdowns you know just me
independent and I mean it was it was
ringing you know maybe I wasn't right
you know I mean even so um ten episodes
down I dropped it and then you know you
of course with the kilometers yeah right
so I I was doing I was I did touchdown
and I was I had a strategic plan where I
went to I just said I'm not performing
at all the clubs like that since I was
stuck in LA
look I'm not gonna perform all the clubs
can perform on a big night so I was
going in on all the big night so last
year of on the beats here Wars I'm in
the club called play house I was doing
yes I went in there and I smashed there
and not before touchdown like three four
times they went crazy and then I started
hearing bus and then you know he asked
me warm sound something like nobody like
see like you know chop it up in the
studio so we chopped it up maybe like
three four days later you know chop it
up is you know as man first and then you
might as businessman you know you got it
Papa you know I mean and then three
three months later like three four
months later they do that Atlantic and
then couple months later okay big deal
man
yeah it's like like what what I know
everybody knows bus that is like super
animated like oh geez man but it's
mailboxes buses crossing the music -
yeah what's it like man like like this
Busta Rhymes the guy that we see or you
know I know he's got a lot of knowledge
man I mean I remember the role his truck
call question right I mean you know he
og man I'm saying and you know this is a
dope man cuz you know he's you know he's
very passionate but then at the same
time it's not you know it's not just
business man he's he's personally know
it's very personal to and then I'm
saying the real family-oriented you know
guy so he's dope yeah when he when you
were performing the record and he fell
yeah what was going through your mind
where bust the rock falls in front of
you why like you stopped you keep going
honey Busta Rhymes a big ass [__] like
you know what when he when he was
falling I I like I saw it when I look
like I collected my birth I saw it and
then that he was fungus sauce no it was
like I don't know what it was slow
motion you don't know me
he's just boom we fell in his head and I
just seen him bleeding in the DJ like
cut it off my oh no we got to turn up
and I mean I definitely wanted to take
all that off of him right really so so
yeah you were making about making a
spectacle right right
even though they caught it anyone yeah
even though there but um I seen I got it
by saying hey bloody I'm just turning up
like oh hell look at this so I'm just I
just turned up man and then um after you
found out he was okay and everything we
joked about it and all that laughed
about it and all that rooms and so it
was crazy man um with Coco is it all I
mean this is like
one of those records that can easily be
one of those songs that like the music
can end up being bigger than the artist
right yeah right because ot Genesis a
lot of people don't know you from
touchdown all right
they just know you as the cocoa guy yeah
yeah and that happens to a lot of our
records the artists you know like like
Flo Rida to me is someone whose rustic
is bigger than him right that's
something that you've kind of already
strategically thought of and are you on
your mind yeah I thought about it but I
mean the only the only way to you know
take care of that man is just keep
dropping yeah yeah consistency is
everything so I don't know I have no
problem with that at home a lot of
people do I mean and then I think that I
have a little bit of an advantage
because that virals will make everything
more friendly 'ti without all the
cocaine yeah yeah and you know I mean
but that that video was was was
everything no you got seventy five
million views on this crazy is crazy
yes crazy is crazy and I never I never
would have thought that record would
have did that's real um now this song
haven't been pretty big for a few months
they've been out of the song is this is
the third month third month let's talk
about the butt cheeks you're getting
right now your groupie game got to be on
another level city services can you
share can you share a single groupie
story with us maybe yeah chick that was
out of line maybe not tell you something
okay so um this is crazy
so angle to Angus I can't I go say
specifically what city okay whatever but
I'm my own who it is yeah thanks a
grandson so we so we um I check inside
the hotel or whatever um till I got a
couple shows it's in the South in the
West it's in the south so check i check
in a check in the hotel or not and um
you know I'm talking to the girl
whatever and she's just like she's like
she's not like
for some strange reason it's like she
was kind of like she wasn't like digging
me or she didn't know who I was not like
that I don't know cockiness right but it
was just like she was just like okay
dude I can't remember the word I'm
looking for
but anyway so um I get Mikey ago up
she's always this no she works yes he
works at the hotel so she's behind the
desk
and so I get I get the key and
everything like that I go upstairs catch
the elevator go upstairs um she did my
phone the phone rings in my bedroom so I
pick up the phone she's like oh he would
see how this one lets you know I'm one
of your biggest fans and that or not I'm
not oh okay good
right she was she was she's alright she
was alright at Tuesday morning she could
maybe this is out so so um this isn't it
this is an afternoon um the phone rings
I assume it's like two minutes after I
get inside the hotel room so um she's
like oh but I want to know if um I don't
know I know I'm not a groupie or
anything you know that's a policy said
she said you know I'm not a groupie or
anything but um when you get downstairs
can you say you know can I take a
picture with you whatever okay cool
that's fine
so I leave cuz I was leaving anyway so I
leave like maybe like 30 minutes late I
leave so I take a picture with and
everything um
I leave I leave the whole day then we go
party I don't club I go perform but now
I'm finally coming back this is that
this is end of the night this is the end
of the night yeah I get in there I'll go
or go to I get in the room I see
chocolate-covered strawberries champagne
all kinda don't tell me she was into no
he wasn't in it in a long letter and she
wrote like a long letter on a paper
napkin she's basically telling me like
you know um she fell on me something you
know kind of ice all over your pillow he
said he said call me so she's stirring
the - and I'm like I'm like well you
know if I was like on some other I
could've got you fired
you are you could have yeah you don't
I'm saying if she met some valuable in
the room yeah she put a number right
here she said call me and let's share it
she said call me when you get back let's
share it you didn't call her no no
that's crazy a stage that stage is not
cleaning it right oh yeah I would check
out the Robin like y'all gonna switch
well yes oh those those well we go
tonight this guy's gonna be live at club
sky he's gonna be doing Coco touchdown
all that stuff so you gotta come out and
see him hit him on instagram ladies
you're single I'm assuming yeah I'm
single - we do have some beautiful
ladies in Tampa and a lot of them are
very [__] so I assume you're gonna
Genesis no it's Genesis is here right
now yeah yeah yeah what what am i
trippin wasn't something that was a
jersey like yes the Genesis